welcome back we are here with the
multi-talented star of inventing anna
anna klumsky
all right you're gonna share one of your
many talents with us tarot card reading
for you i don't know how it works how
does it work well what i like to do is
pull a daily tarot card just a daily one
you can ask yourself i don't know like
what's today about or like what should i
know today what should i look out for
today what's um what's uh in my heart
you know how can
how can i serve life today anything that
you want to know for your day so
take a deep breath
okay and let it out
think of
which what a question for the day would
be for you do i say it out loud you can
if you wish why not will i see him again
okay okay
um
so um make three piles
thinking of your question
great and now you can put them back
together
great and now
i will know if you can see that i don't
know we did that that's what you did
okay
and
and yeah um keep your question in your
mind
and find find a card and
okay that's your card turn it over
all right we have got eight of cups
and what i'm going to ask you
is what stands out that there is a solo
hiker okay
okay on the card
yeah i mean i don't know do you identify
with the with the hiker in this card i
don't know i am definitely the solo
hiker
and i am and and i've never entered
relationships
um
as a whole person
so i've sort of now that i'm re kind of
open to dating again after six years um
and being a single mom and raising my
kids and their dad is happily married
his side of the street's like great and
happy and healthy i'm like oh maybe and
i'm like i have never felt like this in
my life so i'm very happy being i love
it i love it
and if you turn it upside down
we can let all of that other
thing you were hanging on to go i love
that if you turn it upside down you can
let it all go the cup's holding on to
stuff right so let's let's let it go
thank you for this very spiritual moment
yeah isn't it fun i love this i love
this so
thanks for letting me do it thank you
for letting me
work through this meaningful and
important stuff i'm happy to i'm so
excited to tell you that i spent several
hours
just
engrossing myself
falling in love first of all hold on
veep i mean just give me
six emmy nominations yeah
yeah that must be uh no psychic needed
indication you're on the right path yeah
i felt that way i felt yeah a little bit
you know it's uh it yeah it's a good
feeling it's a really it's a nice
feeling but a good peer review is a good
feeling all right so
i have to ask you about inventing anna
um
this show okay so it's shonda rhimes
swinging hard for netflix
yet again
it is a real two-hander with you and
julia garner
it is
so
incredible and luscious and alluring and
exciting and this crazy story yeah i you
know and it's it is an amazing thing to
make a show kind of in real time when so
many people are already so interested in
the story that it's based on it's um
this this young woman for anybody who
like myself did not know about it before
the show
um a young woman anna delvey um several
years ago uh
figured out a way to scam her way up
into like the highest ranks of new york
society um all the glitz and glamour and
um
and i play the reporter who investigates
her story i loved it i was glued at
finally like 11 30. i was like turn it
off go to bed yeah
tomorrow that's great and um so thank
you so much thank you thank you sharing
life
sharing your um
tarot wisdom
and also telling us about your
illustrious career then now
and as we cheer you on into the future
thank you for the future
be sure to watch inventing anna
streaming now on netflix thank you and
we'll be right back
[Music]
you